mec c'est ouf on est enfin à cannes
j'avoue mec la vie de sa une star vite
fait une star c'est plutôt
quand une star t'nb là
quand tes peines tard
quand une star par classe
quand les peines tard quand une star tu
as une piscine
quand t'es pas une star quand une star
un majordome
qui fait prendre en photo par les
paparazzi quand et paint star bonjour
c'est possible au premier tour
non mais de nous adacore autant pour moi
quand une star dans une voiture classe
quand t'es pas une star
quand une star tu pu interviewer
alors je vais monter les marches pour
présenter en effet un court métrage est
alors quand t'es pas une star
franchement je suis je suis pas vraiment
déçu il ya un petit peu de pluie quand
on arrivé là ça va le soleil commence à
ceux à se montrer dans le care oui j'ai
bien apprécié ce petit restaurant là je
me rappelle plus le nom mais belle
entrecôte comme ça à 210 entendu